c'est la grande galerie des héros on y à
rassembler les objets les plus précieux
de l'histoire du concours so lu ment
topissime c'est ça c'est ce que tu
allais dire si oui il faut faire hyper
garde parce que tout est très fragile
tiens par exemple lure de dégâts les
chuchoteurs une fois quelqu'un a cassé
sans faire exprès qu en au dessus mais
ça regarde le célèbre pousse-pousse d'un
sceau de l'empereur faucon jolie châssis
et qu'est ce que tu fais papa faut pas
toucher c'est interdit savoir et pardon
robert sa place oui je crois que ça vaut
mieux csu étaient trop beau et trop bien
ouais c'est cool
à quoi ça sert soit fait tirer dessus
je crois que je me serais fait évident
tu dis d'autant qu'on est là on pourrait
essayer autre chose
en plein air
soit soulagé
c'est ça votre village secret hop je
comprends que vous le cacher si je
vivais ici je ne m'en voudrez pas moi
non plus
ironise il est revenu avec petits loups
tuent
approchez approchez touche mais moi je
vous présente mon fils c'est toi mais
pas du tout qui tu es
josy plus payer ni même bien moi c'est
drôle tu es exactement comme moi en plus
petit et toi tu es com - en plus vieux
et toi qui est comme moi mais en
beaucoup plus gros ouais et toi tu es
comme moi mais plus rien
bonjour je m'appelle mais c'est que les
délicieuses quelle bouteille qu'elle
brosse
c'est très gentil pour mais je préfère
que mes admirateurs fasse ce genre de
commentaires élogieux après la
représentation a eu ça commence quand s
arrête de me dévorer déçu je sais c'est
impossible
qu'est-ce que à mourir des comme ça va
falloir à siri vous situe pas très bons
en jeu mais si tu danses très bien on va
vous coûtera alors débrouille-toi succès
fou mon grand
oui
donc un paravent c'est toi le guerrier
de raconter nous aurons qu'apparemment
thuy car la bête vengeresse le faiseur
de veuves enfin merci pour un peu
j'aurais presque envie de l'épargné ah
ouais tu m'épargnera et sitôt venez
plutôt fait au lieu de jackass est allé
ou passons aux choses sérieuses je vais
m'en parler de ton çi et du dessus de
tous les autres pandas ne tue jackass
que cela casse chacun
j'accueille tujac as tout cela casse